TETRIS
It's the perfect game.
It was the most beautiful thing I'd ever seen.
I played for five minutes,
I still see falling blocks in my dreams.
It's poetry. Art and math
all working in magical synchronicity, it's...
it's the perfect game.
TETRIS
TETRIS,
I don't get it.
It's a combination of tetra, Greek for four,
and tennis.
Tennis?
The Russian inventor he likes tennis.
This game isn't just addictive.
It stays with you.
This is a once in a lifetime opportunity.
Henk, only ten other people in the world have
seen what you are about to see.
It's called the Game Boy.
Package it with TETRIS.
Can you get us the rights?
The Soviet Union has worldwide rights.
Nothing gets out easily.
I'm gonna go to Moscow.
You're walking into a country
that still considers America
enemy numero uno.
Okie Dokie.
You sure you don't have to talk to your
wife about this first?
Pioneers
have to bet the house to win.
But not literally.
Listen,
have you ever heard our apartment this quiet before?
This is the inventor of TETRIS.
Your game is brilliant.
I'm gonna make you a millionaire.
Mr. Rogers,
have you ever negotiated with the Soviets?
We're here for TETRIS.
What did he say? I don't speak Russian.
The most powerful men in Communist Party
is watching you and your family.
Do you know where your husband is?
What the hell is going on?
The world is changing
and Soviet Union will not be left behind.
You want to play with the big boys?
This is how the world works.
Where is my money?
This is insane.
We can't protect you.
Sometimes you got to forget the rules?
♪Will things ever be the same again♪
GO, GO, GO!
♪It's the final♪
♪countdown♪
This is criminal.
The Soviet Union is about to implode.
They're lying, everybody's lying.
Go home!
The calvary is coming.
We don't have time.
I have a plan.
Alexey Alexey... Woah!
Oh, come on you guys are the kings of cliffhangers.
Not too bad.
♪It's the final countdown♪